good morning John it's Wednesday March
4th this is being filmed significantly
in advance because I wanted to do
something weird and I'm trying it out
this is called truth or fail truth or
fail is a new fun thing that I've
created I'm gonna tell you two facts and
you are going to tell me which one is
true or you will fail this is going to
get you through a sequence of videos and
if you are correct all 5 times you will
receive a very special prize and I'm not
telling you what that surprise is this
is Hank from the future this is actually
now whereas that was recorded a long
time ago obviously I'm not at home
because I don't have a baby mobile baby
mobile a baby mobile mobile I don't even
know what that thing is called but I am
just here with a little bit of news that
one of the questions I was wrong so in
the one about the perfect strangers
actually it was the theme from growing
pains I'm sorry a little hint from
future Hank click on the perfect
strangers one also there are four not
five questions to answer and for some
reason this video didn't show but a lot
of people's subscription boxes so I'm
sorry about that
maybe this one will it's all part of
figuring out how true the feel is going
to work and I hope that you enjoy it
truth or fail question one John Green
won his first writing award when he was
8 or Helen Hunt is the oldest Hank green
song that you have ever heard